oftentimes you hear people say that
they've done double dutch but most
people have never experienced what
double dutch is now it's a competitive
sport we jump in so that you'll be able
to win my name is Jenna Robinson and I'm
a part of Boise little SS team which is
located in north New Jersey I'm 17 years
old and I've been jumping double-dutch
for five years I practice with a double
dutch team three times a week we can be
four times a year and it leads up to the
world competition and my team has 19
world championship titles we're
currently in competition season and
everyone is aiming to win the trophy
[Music]
during the double dutch it gave me a
safe place they gave me a home this
isn't just jumping rope I was born and
raised in Newark New Jersey and Newark
is a city where a lot of violence occurs
it's not always safe to be outside a lot
of shootings happening I just never know
what to expect
growing up I didn't have the mother
relationship with my with my own mother
so I feel like coming to double dutch
has really opened my eyes and let me
know that there is people who care about
me I have a support system whenever I
need it
double dutch is where I need to be it
takes a person with indoors a person
with strength takes a person would
suffice in sata2 in order to be a winner
in order to be that person who knows how
to jump and SS competition the most
important component of those that is
speed that's how fast the jumper and the
Rope can jump
given the support to the jumper is a job
that's really important to me because
growing up I didn't have that support
and I know that I want to give to
support that I never had to the person
who's in the world too so they can know
that no matter how many mistakes you did
you can come back from it you still want
to be a one adds another day they have
what it takes to won the tournament
[Music]